[Music]
okay let's get right to the jokes uh
this is true last week i nearly heard a
habitat heart a heart attack oh my god
sorry i nearly had a heart i heart oh my
god um last week i heard a heart had a
heart uh last week i got my heart on
caught in a hammock there we go ah
oh
i couldn't get it out
and i couldn't get it out but that's
fine because whenever you're faced with
a life or death situation like that it
forces you to look back on life you get
nostalgic but that can be dangerous
because sure we have fond memories that
fill us with joy
but i also have regrets
like when i was 13
i farted in a mayonnaise jar
and i recapped it
and i put it in the refrigerator
and soon afterwards i watched my
grandmother
assemble a ham cheese and mayonnaise
sandwich
and then i watched her eat it
but i also have regrets
things i wish i didn't do
don't clap it's not that funny
but one regret i do have is uh i bought
my nephew a kite for christmas yeah i
will never ever buy another child a kite
for christmas because kites are like
smoke signals to pedophiles all right
they know what's on the other end of the
string okay
it's called dinner well i don't know if
they're eating the children it doesn't
matter
i gotta look that up
but what's interesting is i sent my
friend adam a text and then my friend
adam texted me back and the text that
adam wrote me read
call me in 10 minutes or else i'm having
a shower
yeah adam doesn't really know how to
threaten people if you think about it i
mean think about it you're going to have
to threaten
moves from you guys you're going to move
because uh i'll move you to the back
just up here yeah and if you don't know
are you together i don't know if i
should start again oh okay um excuse me
we're gonna move this group
excuse me yep hi sorry
what are you doing oh i'm just moving
some people trying to arrange the crowd
for the segment okay yeah well
i'm trying to work here so oh me too so
we have a lot in common i guess
right no i i don't think you understand
like i think what i'm doing is a little
bit more important than what you're
doing right now all right is it okay
yeah pedophile joke i'm trying to move
them so that i can
have an answer
what i'm doing is actually i think do
you think this is easy i think it's very
easy do you think what i'm doing you
think this is easy you think this is
easy take that do you want to do it i
haven't done anything
oh
my god
where are you supposed to sit am i gonna
put you over here
guys guys guys
guys
guys
guys you're both being incredibly
unprofessional yeah and i don't even
think we have ushers yeah we don't that
is yeah
i mean for god's sake show some maturity
oh i'm sorry
do you think this is easy
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
sarah chuck
[Applause]
hey sarah are you promoting anything uh
yes
actually i am oh that's great but we're
all out of time
okay wow
ladies and gentlemen huh i've been
hosting a late night show for 20 years
now and i think i have to say john door
is the best comic i have ever seen round
of applause
john doerr is a genius i don't know why
john doerr isn't the host of conan well
that's our show i want to thank my guest
john door